500 jours 500 jours c'est le nombre de
jours qu'il nous reste avant la
cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
olympiques de Paris la parade nautique
ou des fils ronds les 10000 athlètes sur
6 km est un lourd des filles en matière
de sécurité le budget que leur annoncé
maîtrisée à hauteur de 8 milliards
d'euros sans de plus en plus difficile à
tenir et la France n'a pas droit à
l'erreur mais ma question porte sur une
autre difficulté celle qui concerne la
situation et la capacité d'accueil des
hôpitaux pendant que ce dérouleront les
Jeux Olympiques cet été pour ce qui
concerne les 15000 athlètes et ceux qui
les accompagnent un centre de santé sera
créé en lien avec la PHP mais pour ce
qui concerne les plus de 10 millions de
visiteurs attendus que compte faire le
gouvernement les hôpitaux de Parisiens
ont en normal peine à fonctionner le
service d'urgence sont débordés et trop
de lits de chirurgie sont aujourd'hui
fermés ajoutons de surcroît qu'en plein
été en raison des congés les équipes
médicales sont réduites gouverner c'est
prévoir alors Monsieur le Ministre
qu'avez-vous prévu pour assurer le
fonctionnement des hôpitaux parisiens
pour faire face aux soins courants et à
l'affût de visiteurs pendant les Jeux
Olympiques